Musik
Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Vielen Dank für dieses fantastische Intro von Ben!
Hey, vielen Dank, Ben von den Rocket Beans.
Ah, Ben von den Rocket Beans. Ah, Ben von Rocket Beans. Grossartig. Toller Grafiker, toller Komponist, mittelmässiger Mensch. Ja, okay, da wollte ich gerade fragen. Das hört man aber ein bisschen raus. Merkt man ja auch mittlerweile, die grossen Künstler haben immer so Schattenseiden. Hinter dem Intro hat so viel Kunst und Geschmack und Stil gesteckt. Vielleicht schon dachte, das ist ein menschlicher Abgrund dahinter. Toll, ein bisschen Rick-and-Morty-Style, gefällt mir ganz gut. Alles drin. Hast du dir überlegt, dass du... Nee, nicht alles. Du hast ja, gut, technisch gesehen nicht alles. Du bist ja weiterhin auf der Suche nach einer Persönlichkeit. Hast du dir mal überlegt, so eine Schattenseite anzugehen? Also wirklich mal zu sagen, mal in die dunklen Gefilde abzusteigen? Das kommt dann in 20 Jahren raus, dass du damals ... Nee, tatsächlich habe ich aber manchmal gerade gelernt, wie befreiend es ist, Menschen beruflich anzuschnauzen. Wirklich, das machst du? Das ist mir noch nie passiert, habe ich auch noch nie gemacht. Du hast mich mal angeschnauzt. Wir haben schon lange, ja das stimmt, wir haben lange zusammengearbeitet und du weißt, ich schnauze nicht häufig Leute an. Das stimmt. Eigentlich gar nicht. Du bist sehr anspruchsvoll, aber du versprichst auch die Aura, dass man Lust hat, sein Bestes zu geben. Und ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin häufig gut gelaunt, also ich bin wirklich 90% gut gelaunt. Aber da war ich wirklich auf diese Person einfach sauer und hab die wirklich angeschissen am Telefon, richtig angeschissen, weil es auch wirklich problematisch wurde, und das Produkt, für das ich gearbeitet habe, drohte dadurch schlechter zu werden. Und dann da kickt, dann wurde ich getriggert auf jeden Fall. So Mutterinstinkt vielleicht so ein bisschen, ne? Ja, oder Vaterinstinkt. Die Wölfe greifen dein Kind an. Ja, gut, Mutterinstinkt. Und dann war ich wirklich sauer, habe ich die Person angeschissen, am nächsten Tag kam die Person zu mir und hat gesagt, ich will mich noch mal bedanken bei dir, wie positiv du bist und wie toll du immer alles ausdrückst und dass du der einzige bist, der hier immer positiv bleibt und immer einen guten Ton findet. Und ich dachte mir, entweder hat diese Person die Brigitte gelesen und so einen, wie man mit schwierigen, vorgesetzten Umgebhebeln, Artikel oder sowas. Ja, so umgekehrte Psychologie, ja. Und wendet sowas an, aber auf der anderen Seite wusste sie auch, dass sie von allen Leuten angeschissen wurde, weil sie einfach einen grauenvollen Job gemacht hat in dem Moment, in der Zeit. Und deswegen glaube ich auch, dass ich schon der bin, der am nettesten noch zu ihr war, obwohl ich sauer wurde. Aber war denn jemand mit dir im Raum? Also du hast ja im Telefon dieses Gespräch. War da jemand mit im Raum? Nee, nee. Hätte dich das beeinflusst? Ja. Ja? Ja. Dann wäre direkt so, hi, hey, ich wollte nur mal ganz kurz fragen, passt überhaupt, sorry, ganz kurz, passt überhaupt? Ja. So wäre ich dann, wenn jemand im Raum ist. Man verändert auch die Stimme, je nachdem, wie man telefoniert. Das ist ein ganz kommend vernommen. Läufst du auch immer, wenn du telefonierst? Ich rase durch die Wohnung. Nicht nur, also klar, mittlerweile habe ich nur noch ein Handy, aber damals auch mit Festnetz bin ich immer rumgerast durch die Wohnung. Ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen, eine Zeit, in der die Telefone statisch waren. Und es gibt ja manche Telefone, gerade in amerikanischen Filmen und Serien sieht man das manchmal, die so acht Meter lange Kabel haben. Wo man wirklich durchs ganze Haus laufen kann. Überall ist voll Kabel irgendwann.
Und immer dieses Kabel haben, das finde ich immer interessant, aber tatsächlich bei mir auch. Ich rase durch die Wohnung, ich heize durch die Wohnung. Aber mir ist teilweise auch langweilig bei Telefonaten, also jetzt nichts gegen meine... Ich langweile auch wirklich. Nichts gegen meinen Sprechspartner, aber zum Beispiel habe ich letztens ein Telefonat geführt, da habe ich gerade Spaghetti gekocht. und dann hat die am anderen Ende erzählt und erzählt. Und ich habe dann immer so mein Handy so ganz langsam über das blubbernde Wasser so gehalten. Einfach das bisschen reagiert. Das ist ja völlig kommentarlos. Ja, was ich gemacht habe, war nämlich, ich habe nebenbei angefangen, Geschirr zu waschen, zu spülen. Und ich dachte mir, klingt das jetzt vielleicht so, als ob ich auf dem Klo bin. Also klingt das jetzt, weil ich habe so einen Wasserhahn, der hat nicht mehr so viel Druck und es klingt so ein bisschen, so als ob man pinkelt, wenn man den anmacht. Und dann habe ich halt eine Tasse drunter gehalten und habe die Tasse so ein bisschen ausgespült, was drin war, um das dann in die Spülmaschine zu packen, aber so ein bisschen vorzuspülen. Aber da habe ich telefoniert, ich dachte mir, auch ein bisschen lustig, wenn diese Person denkt, oh, dieser No Bullshit,shit-Stefan, am Telefon einfach knallt aufs Klo gehen.
Aber ist es denn unhöflich, was zu machen, während man telefoniert? Aufs Klo gehen schon. Zu essen auch? Also ich hätte, glaube ich, kein Problem damit. Also jetzt wirklich was komplett anderes. Wenn du nur noch blubbern hörst plötzlich, muss man auch denken, was stimmt mit dem nicht? An welchem Punkt sagt die andere Person, alles in Ordnung da drüben, einfach blubblubblubblub. Aber mir ist auch mal aufgefallen, bei einem Business-Teleat, was wir neulich hatten, wo wir auf einer Seite waren und mit einer anderen Partei telefoniert haben, ist mir auch mal aufgefallen, wo ich schon lange drüber nachgedacht habe bei Telefonaten. Weil ich finde, Telefonate fressen Zeit.
Also ein Telefonat ist 20 Prozent die Dinge besprechen, die man besprechen will und 80 Prozent wiederholen, das Gesagte wiederholen. Okay, also nochmal zusammenfassen, so ein Recap. Also wir fassen zusammen, ich melde mich morgen und dann gucken wir mal einfach, wie wir es machen. Genau, ich würde sagen, du meldest dich einfach morgen und dann können wir weitergucken und bis dahin wollen wir sagen. Wie gesagt, wir sagen einfach, wir machen das mit den fünf Flaschen und dann gucken wir, ob noch mal zwei dazukommen oder sowas. Im Endeffekt ist ja auch egal. Du, im Endeffekt würde ich sagen, wir haben uns jetzt auf die fünf Flaschen geeinigt und wenn noch was aufkommt, dann lass uns dann einfach dann noch mal telefonieren. Genau, man ist ja nicht festgelegt mit diesen fünf Flaschen. Ich würde aber sagen, wir machen die jetzt einfach mal, aus den Gründen, die wir gerade genannt haben. Genau, ich habe gar nichts gegen fünf, wie gesagt, halte mich auf dem Laufenden, wenn noch was ist. Es ist absurd, und dann spricht man wirklich die ganze Zeit nochmal darüber, und dann wird oft über den nächsten Besprechungstermin verhandelt. Es ist wirklich seltsam. Aber es ist ganz wenig nur wirklich Informationsaustausch. Ich glaube, das hängt damit zusammen, dass niemand das Gespräch beenden möchte. Weil gerade in so einem Geschäftsgespräch will man ja motiviert erscheinen. Man sucht ja das Gespräch, man will die Kommunikation, man will mit dem anderen zusammenarbeiten. Und wenn jemand sagt, sag mal fünf Flaschen, alles klar, ciao, wenn man direkt auflegt. Aber ohne Scheiss Challenge. Wahrscheinlich ist es besser, ja. Challenge, ohne Scheiss, mach das mal. Beende ein Gespräch so früh wie möglich. Nee, beende ein Gespräch, wenn alle wichtigen Informationen ausgetauscht wurden. Das fühlt sich, glaube ich, total fies und frech an, wenn man das macht, wenn man sagt, hey, ich wollte mal fragen, wann wir uns morgen treffen wollen. 18 Uhr, alles klar, ciao. Ja, ich glaube, man kommt mega souverän rüber. Stefan war sehr kurz ab heute am Telefon, kommt dann sowas. Aber der hat bestimmt viel zu tun, also, ne? Ja. Ich finde, das ist eine gute Idee. Fünf Flaschen und dann nicht mal ciao sagen, sondern einfach direkt aufnehmen. Direkt aufnehmen. Einfach klack weg, ich hab alles. Man hat einen Zehn-Punkte-Plan für euch. Für alle Zuhörer da draußen mal einen Zehn-Punkte-Plan für bis nächste Woche. Auf Punkt eins beendet ein Gespräch am Telefon, sobald alles gesagt wird. Das ist ja sehr optimistisch. Wollen wir nicht sagen, drei Punkte Plan. Aber es sind immer zehn Punkte Pläne. Punkt zwei, setze dir hohe Ziele. Aber man muss doch sagen, bei Politikern ist es oft ein Zehn-Punkte-Plan.
Aber das klingt so, als ob alle
Probleme mit zehn Punkten,
manche Probleme verdienen nur
vier Punkte. Und dann finde ich,
dann ist doch die letzten sechs Jahre nur Bullshit
oder leichte Variationen von den davor genannt.
Er ist dann so, so, wir machen was
zum Klimawandel, wir haben zwei Punkte-Plan
ausgearbeitet, wir machen das und das. Mehr nicht. Das ist ein sehr komplexes Problem doch eigentlich. Ja, okay, vielleicht, lass uns morgen nochmal telefonieren, wir legen noch ein paar Punkte oben drauf. Kann sich jemand um den Mann da hinten kümmern? Wir haben keine Security. Drei Punkteplan, Security einführen. Was ist der Punkteplan mit den wenigsten Punkten der Geschichte? So Wilsonplan oder so? Es sind immer mindestens fünf oder sechs. Marshallplan ist ein Plan. Die müssen immer so kommen. Ein Punkteplan. Wir haben jetzt erst eineinhalb vielleicht, wenn es hochkommt. Wenn es hochkommt. Wenn die uns den durchgehen lassen. Nein, es ist viel zu wenig. Aber man kennt das. Aufzählungen sind aber immer gut, weil Aufzählungen immer so, wir müssen die Schadstoffe verringern und wir müssen nur die Schadstoffe verringern. Das reicht schon. Strukturiert Pläne. Aber man kennt das ja aus der Schule zum Beispiel oder aus einer Hausarbeit, die man mal schreiben musste, dass man auf eine gewisse Zahl kommen muss. Total. Und man pulchelt sich dann irgendwann durch drum herum. Das passt zu unserem Thema, denn Thais, unsere
Schülerpraktikantin vor wenigen Wochen,
hat uns jetzt ihren Praktikumsbericht
geschickt. Ja, sie hat lange daran gearbeitet
und ehrlich gesagt war ich erstaunt,
weil ich dachte, weil mein Praktikumsbericht
bestand daraus irgendwie so ein
fünf Seiten vorgedrucktes
Dokument, wo man nur ankreuzen
musste, so wie zufrieden waren sie.
Arbeitsklima. Sie war der erste Tag und dann waren so fünf
Zeilen vorgedruckt, so fünf, also
wirklich halte ich kurz, weil
Und Dokument, wo man nur ankreuzen musste, so wie zufrieden waren sie. Wie war der erste Tag und dann waren so fünf Zeilen vorgedruckt, so fünf, also wirklich halte ich kurz, weil auch die Lehrer haben natürlich Interesse daran, das ist kurz geil. Wenn sie mehr Platz brauchen, bitte die Rückseite benutzen. Man sagt so, nein, nein. Wir wissen beide, dass es nicht passiert. Ich war bei der NASA, aber nein. Ich war im Weltall bei der NASA für ein Praktikum, nein. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, mein Gott, Thais, reiss dich zusammen, das kann doch nicht so schwer sein, weil sie jetzt irgendwie drei Wochen gebraucht hat. Dann habe ich das Ding aber gesehen, meine Herren, das ist ja wirklich eine halbe Doktorarbeit, die sie geschrieben hat, mit Bildern und mit Sachen, also wirklich auch grafisch, layoutmäßig aufgearbeitet. Ja, finde ich ganz, ganz toll gemacht. Finde ich toll. Könntest du denn heutzutage zur Schule dazu, auch so Präsentationssachen mitzulernen, also dann die Font auswählen und sie hat da hier so eine blaue Farbe genommen? Sie hat sich aber nicht für das Inhaltsverzeichnis entschieden, was die Textverarbeitungsprogramme automatisch erstellen, sondern für das, und ich kenne das ganz gut, man versucht selber. Das Typische, man versucht selber ein Inhaltsverzeichnis zu erstellen. Und dann kommt das zum Problem, dass man nicht genau weiß, wie man die Zahlen rechtsbündig bekommt, in die gleiche Zeile, wo auch was linksbündig schon steht. Aber das ist ja großartig. Sie fängt an mit Inhalt und dann vier mal die Zahl vier. Yeah, weil alles oh scheiße, vier ist richtig. Ja. Oh, jetzt bin ich, hallo, Herr Böhmermann. abend der böhmermann jetzt bist du leider im podcast-ovo geladen brauchst du irgendwas brauchst du was zu trinken das kennt man ja wenn man einfach in den raum läuft und dann plötzlich im podcast-ovo landen nee schnittraum ist drüben ist so ein stimmige gehört habe und dachte dasalt, dass sie es nicht verwendet. Okay, alles klar. Gut, schönen Abend, Herr Dürmer.
Tschau, schönen Abend noch.
Aber das ist ja auch großartig.
Es fängt an mit viertens, einfach no bullshit, einfach so.
Ich habe keine Zeit für eins, zwei, drei.
Punkt vier.
Das stimmt schon, ne?
Vier mal Punkt vier.
Aber auch vier mal Punkt vier.
Ich bin, ich muss sagen, ich freue mich jetzt schon auf Seite vier.
Seite vier ist...
Ach, das ist Seite vier.
Seite vier, ja.
Ach, jetzt check ich's. Ich dachte, das ist eine Liste. Oh, das finde ich ja toll, wie er sich amüsiert, über etwas, was so falsch stand. Das ist auch nicht so schlecht. Das zeigt ja auch so ein bisschen, dass wenn man ein gewisses Weltbild hat, darüber sich auch freuen. Jetzt verstehe ich's, das ist alles auf Seite vier. Deswegen meine ich ja, also du musst ja die Seitenzahl rechtsbündig hinbekommen. Das ist natürlich ein großes Problem, weil der Inhalt ja linksbündig ist. Naja, man
kennt es, ich versuche es mal mit Punkten, aber dann verrutscht immer alles und es ist schwierig. Aber dann
schreibt man doch eine vier und dann alles, was auf der Seite ist, drunter. Man schreibt doch nicht zu jedem Punkt eine vier. Aber gut, das sind jetzt Details. Ja, aber was, wenn nicht Details, können wir Ist ... also ...
Boah!
Ist jetzt ...
Hey, Mann!
Naja, na ja, na ja.
Aua, okay.
Ja, ja.
Ist okay. Also, ist jetzt ... Hey, Mann! Na ja, na ja.
Aua, okay.
Ja, ja.
Ist okay.
Toll.
So, wollen wir schon mal ein bisschen durchskippen durchs Inhaltsverfahren.
Also, ich überfliege mal so ein bisschen.
Zwei Partikumsplätze, Lage, Branche, Berufe, Firmenhistorie, soziale Strukturen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Genauer Berichte eines Tagesverlaufs, Charakterisierung der eigenen Tätigkeit, etc. Welche neuen Erfahrungen blieb viel, zu viel, gar nichts unklar? Die Überschriften werden immer erzählerischer. Mein persönlicher Wert des Praktikums. Das macht auf keiner Ebene Sinn. Wir haben, als ich es auch schon überflogen habe, Thais, wir haben eine Menge Rechtschreibfehler. Holy shit, also Respekt für alles, was Layout und so betrifft. Ja, wobei Serifenschriften auch nicht mehr. Na ja, ist da in Ordnung. Thais ist 16, da kann man sich mal so eine Serif auch rausballern. Moment mal, warum sind die drei ersten Personen, die abgebildet sind, warum ist es niemand von uns? Das stimmt schon auch, ja. Du, ich glaube, sie hat versucht, also ... Das Podcast-Ufo so kaschieren. Richtig, sie hat versucht, sie hat in den Praktikumsbericht vom Podcast-Ufo das Podcast-Ufo so klein zu halten, wie es geht. Er steht auch darüber zwei Wochen bei der Bild- und Tonfabrik und dem Podcast-Ufo. Vollkommen falsch geschrieben auch. Alles falsch geschrieben und auch durchdekliniert auch falsch. So, clever, Eita ist es klüger, als wir dachten, das ist so das Staffelfinale, sie wollte eigentlich ein Praktikum bei der BTF und hat sich über uns erschlichen. Und das ist gar nicht so dumm eigentlich. Das ist gar nicht so blöd. Quelle Wikipedia sollte man vielleicht nicht tun. Ja, nimm das, was bei Wikipedia als Quelle angegeben ist, ist nicht so schwer. Das ist der Trick, ja. Das ist der einzige Trick, der einen Bachelor von einem Professor unterscheidet. Am Set ist allerdings der Regisseur derjenige, der den Ton angibt. Ja. Nicht der Tonmann? Er sagt, wo und wie die Kamera zu filmen hat, ob das Bühnenbild noch geändert werden muss und wie der Schauspieler seine Rolle verkörpern soll. Toll! Und auf welcher Seite erscheinen wir das erste Mal? Wir sind noch nicht erschienen. Wir sind noch nicht erschienen auf Seite 6. Wir sind auf Seite sechs, da war mein Praktikumsbericht schon vorbei. Seit drei Seiten. Wahnsinn. So, Bedeutung für Beruf, Zukunft stehen wir auch gar nicht. Ah, da ist ein Absatz. Podcasts stammen ursprünglich aus der Unterhaltungsbranche der USA. Im deutschsprachigen Raum haben das Podcast-Ufo mit Autoren und Schauspielern dieses Format adaptiert. als es in Deutschland noch keine grosse Rolle spielte. Sie zählen hier zu den ersten, die mit diesem Unterhaltungsgenre anfingen und sind bis jetzt erfolgreich damit. In letzter Zeit schossen immer mehr Deutsche auf Podcast und die Nachfrage nach neuen Folgen steigt in zunehmendem Masse. Es schwankt zwischen furchtbarer Grammatik und extrem grossen Wortschatz. Das ist die Spannweite. Also was wie zunehmendem Maße. Ja, ja, das stimmt schon. Aber Moment mal. Podcast entsprungen dem Unterhaltungsprojekt. Im deutschsprachigen Raum haben das Podcast-Ufo mit Autoren und Schauspielern dieses Format adaptiert. Wir haben Podcasts adaptiert. Wer sind diese Autoren und Schauspieler? Nee, sie meint uns. Aber können Sie nicht einfach mal unseren Namen erwähnen? Nee, sie meint uns. Wir sind auf Seite sechs. Sie meint uns, dich mit Schauspielern, mich mit Autoren. Autoren. Du bist aber mehr als ein Autor, Stefan. Das muss es wirklich nicht sein. Du bist auch mehr als ein Schauspieler. Du bist Web Webstar, Influencer, Webexperte, Podcaster, Twitch-Streamer mittlerweile.
Du bist Moderator.
Ja. Aber gut.
Überblick über den Praktikumsverlauf. Da auch nichts von uns. Da.
Nee, auch nicht.
Da das Podcast-Ufo von der BTF unterstützt wird, kann es in den Büros in Köln-Ehrenfeld aufnehmen und auch deren Technik, wie zum Beispiel Mikrofone, benutzen. In der BTF war ich ein, das sind unsere Mikros. Oh Mann, ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht, ich dachte, da geht es viel mehr um uns. So, genauer Bericht eines Tagesverlaufs oder eines Arbeitsvorgangs. Um ein Interview für die Folge des Podcast-Ufos zu produzieren, musste ich folgende Arbeitsschritte befolgen. Erstens, mit dem Thema aus... Das finde ich gut,ens, Fragen aufstellen, drittens, auf der Strasse und bei Veranstaltungen Interviewpartner heraussuchen, die damit einverstanden sind, dass ihre Aussagen veröffentlicht werden, Viertens, zum Hause aus den Interviewaufnahmen interessante Antworten mit einem Audiobearbeitungsprogramm herausschneiden. Also die interessanten wegschneiden, das neue Audiospur stellen und dort von mir gestellte Fragen und die ausgewählten Antworten zusammenführen. Wie im Lehrbuch haben wir das beigebracht, wie man das macht. Ich bin ein bisschen stolz auf Sie. Nur nichts über Qualität oder Inhalt. Sechstens das Resultat per Dropbox bereitstellen, damit das Ergebnis in die kommende Folge hereingeschnitten werden kann. Denn jeder weiß, dass Dropbox das macht. Ist nicht so, dass ich danach, dass sie das so mir geschickt hat, nein. Ich bin gespannt, wie oft die Verben hereingeschnitten und herausgeschnitten noch kommen. Diese Arbeitsvorgänge können je nach Antworten und Anzahl der Befragen mehrere Tage Arbeit in Anspruch nehmen. Mehrere Tage. Das sind Fotos von uns. Oh! Holy shit. Podcasts, bei Aufnahmen und Meetings, Dabeisein und Interviews für die Folge führen und schneiden. Guck mal, wie viel aussehen. Das sind komplett schiefe Bilder von uns. Aber auch geheim aufgenommene Bilder wieder von uns. Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze werden eine Aufnahme. Ich sehe exakt so aus wie heute. Ich habe exakt dieselbe Hose an. Aber ich sehe aus wie in 50 Jahren. Du siehst wirklich gut aus. Das ist ganz schlimm. Wahnsinn. Naja, es ist ein bisschen enttäuschend, weil man, glaube ich,kt, wer ihre Favoriten waren während des Praktikums und das sind nicht wir. Viele Bilder von Neomagazindrehs. Aber man muss sagen, jedes Bild sieht im Geheimen aufgenommen aus. Ja, ich glaube, das hat sie auch gemacht. Sie betont, wie wichtig es ist, darauf zu achten, dass die Leute damit einverstanden sind, dass sie veröffentlicht werden, hat aber ausschließlich geheim gemachte Bilder. Also jedes Bild hat, muss man sagen, etwas im Vordergrund, was verschwommen ist, also wohinter das Handy versteckt war oder jemand, der sagt, bitte fotografiere mich. Kommen wir zum Fazit, kommen wir zum Fazit. Bei den Aufnahmen des Vorgangs konnte ich mitsprechen und war auf Sendung, sie konnte mitsprechen. Folgende Fähigkeiten waren von Nöten. Kommunikationsfähigkeit, Eigeninitiative, Selbstständigkeit, Kreativität, Fähigkeit zu improvisieren, Humor. Das sind Fotos von uns in Wien. Das interessanteste Erlebnis war, dass ich mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will bei dem Podcast, den ich selbst seit langem regelmässig höre, zusammenarbeiten dürfte.
Für mich waren die beiden immer eine Art Idole, da sie mit ihrer Kreativität ein eigenes Projekt schufen
und aus einem Amateur-Podcast mittlerweile eine erfolgreiche kleine Show wurde,
mit der sie viele Fans erreichen und sogar auf grossen Bühnen auftreten.
Für mich war es also schon allein grossartig, mit ihnen zusammen bei ihrer Aufnahme zu sitzen
und einen kleinen Einblick in die Arbeit und Routine hinter dem Podcast zu bekommen. Dafür war es für mich eine grosse Ehre bei den Folgen, die in der Zeit, in der ich mein Praktikum hatte, mitzusprechen und den Zuhörern verschiedene von mir geschnittene, geskriptete und aufgenommene Interviews zu präsentieren. Es war auch ein sehr interessantes und unvergessliches Erlebnis, zusammen mit Bela B., einem Mitglied der Punkband Die Ärzte, ehemal Sonnensch, Neomagazin-Quatsch, bla bla bla, Beurteilung des Praktikums. So, jetzt will ich mal wissen, wie sie es beurteilt. Vor und hinter der Kamera oder Mikrofon zu sein und gemeinsam mit kreativen Menschen zu arbeiten, war für mich hochinteressant. Ich lernte. Gut, jetzt kommt nichts von dem, was ich oben genannt habe, wie man am Computer Tonspuren für einen Podcast schneidet, ein Interview zu führen, selbstständig jeden Tag in eine für mich fremde Gegend zu fahren. Kein Wort davon, dass sie fucking 700 Euro verdient hat, indem sie mit fadenscheinigen Methoden eine arme Charity-Organisation ausgenutzt hat. Blieb viel, zu viel, gar nichts unklar, meistens blieb nichts unklar und selbst wenn, so war immer ein Ansprechpartner in der Nähe, der mir gerne jede Frage beantwortete. Aber jetzt kommt ein Tweet. Jetzt kommt ein Tweet. Oh, und da unten ist sie nochmal als Mitarbeiterin des Monats in der Folge, zusammen mit Paul. Sehr süss. Bei dem Podcast-Ufo fand ich sehr positiv, dass ich meine eigene Kreativität freien Lauf lassen konnte. Mein Interviewpartner hätte ich mir frei auswählen können, und auch Themen, die ich ansprach, waren mir überlassen. Familiär, offen und herzlich. Mitsprechen. Toll. Wirkt sich das Praktikum auf deinen eigenen Berufswunsch aus? Mein Praktikum hat mir vor nochmals sehr gut vor... Was? Mein Praktikum hat mir vor nochmals sehr gut vor Augen geführt, wie viel Spaß ich bei Fernseh- und Radioaufnahmen habe und dass ich, so meinen es zumindest meine Praktikumsbetreuer der BTF, Florentin und Stefan des Podcast-Ufos Potenzial besäße. Mein Traum ist es nun, nach meinem Schulabschluss an einer Universität, die mir die Autoren empfahlen, Film und Fernsehen zu studieren. Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch, Thais. Also, das scheint eine Empfehlung von dir gewesen zu sein. Nee. Ich hab dir nichts davon empfohlen. Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, das ist falsch verstanden. Na ja, cool, freut mich sehr. Vielen Dank, Thais, für diesen abschließenden Bericht. Wir haben auch viel gelernt. Wir müssen natürlich auch für unser nächstes Praktikum gucken, was wir besser machen können. Aber machen wir das jetzt jedes Jahr? Haben wir jedes Jahr eine Schleppartikel? Nein, auf jeden Fall. Es war viel zu viel Arbeit. Nein, nein, nein. Thais ist was Besonderes, sie ist einmalig und das soll es auch bleiben. Teils sichartig. Sie arbeitet ja auch weiterhin und steuert ihren Beitrag dabei, damit wir immer diese jugendliche Frische auch weiterhin im Podcast haben, die, und da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, die wir langsam vermissen lassen. Du hast im Vorgespräch das Wort Wack gesagt, ich habe es dir nicht abgenommen. Ich habe es dir nicht abgenommen. Nee, auch weil ich immer nicht weiß, man kennt es dann oft nur gelesen, wie man das dann sagt. Richtig, ja, ja. Es ist schwierig, sich so eine jugendliche Sprache anzulesen. Gerade so diese Twittersprache auch irgendwie so Uff und so, man weiss immer nicht, was ist das Abkürzungen für irgendwas, man ist völlig raus, es ist schwierig. Ich musste für die Serie in der Tonkabine ... Manchmal laufen ja im Hintergrund Leute vorbei, die reden, und dann werden die nachvertont, und die müssen dann irgendwas sagen. Und dann kam halt an, das war der furchtbarste Tag des letzten Jahres, kamen von morgens bis abends kleine Kinder und Jugendliche und es wurde immer älter im Laufe des Tages vorbei und mussten dann. Die wurden sortiert nach Alter, nach Altersklassen und dann so ab 14 Uhr kamen dann die 16-Jährigen, die Jungs und die coolen Mädels und ich dann da da an meinem mikrofon und dann waren die halt in der tonkabine ich musste den immer sagen und dann gab es halt verschiedene szenen wo ich denen sagen musste was jetzt sagen sollen und du musst halt Regieanweisungen geben du kannst nicht genau sagen was sie machen müssen weil dann machen sie nur das also die müssen ja schon irgendwie auch eine gewisse Autorizität ausstrahlen und ich habe gemerkt ich habe erst mal habe ich mich viel jünger gestellt als ich bin so Wörter wie, hat er immer aufs Mikrofon gedrückt, auf den Sprechknopf und dann so was so, yo, eine Sache noch und alle, die auch neben mir im Raum seien, sagen auch so, was ist mit dir denn los, aber man will den Gefallen, deswegen spricht man anders, hat bei mir gar nicht funktioniert, ich habe gemerkt, ich habe auf jeden Fall komplett jeglichen Bezug zur Jugend verloren. Und dann ging es um Musik und sowas, wo ich auch... Lil Peep hast du doch jetzt gelernt von Thais. Red mal über Lil Peep, der kommt jetzt nach Köln. Welchen Song würdet ihr euch in der Bar wünschen? Was würdet ihr euch beim DJ wünschen? Lil Peep? Aber was sind denn so Sätze, die man immer gut im Hintergrund sagen kann? Weil du kannst ja nicht den Anfang eines Gesprächs machen. Nee, meistens musst du direkt rein. Sondern es muss so mittendrin sein. Ich habe oft dann sowas gesagt, also über belanglose Sachen. Ich glaube, wenn man im Hintergrund ist, es geht ja eh nur darum, dass man so ein Grundrauschen wahrnimmt, wenn man mal genau hinhört, dass es Sinn ergibt. Es geht ja wirklich gar nicht um Unterhaltung, deswegen immer über Hausaufgaben in der Schule reden oder über einen süßen Jungen oder ein süsses Mädel oder sowas, dass die da typische Teenagergespräche führen. Das hat immer ganz gut funktioniert auch. Meistens habe ich die aber einfach in die Tonkabine gestellt und dann einfach aufgenommen, aufnehmen lassen. Die haben einfach irgendwann eine normale Bild. Die haben einfach denen mal eine Szene gezeigt und dann haben die über diese Szene gesprochen. Das ist ganz übrigens lustig. Und es kann sein, dass in der Serie irgendwann so mega Meta-mäßig Dinge reingeschnitten werden, weil meistens habe ich die nur die Szene kommentieren lassen, das aufgenommen und das dann reinschneiden. Also es kann wirklich sein, dass in der Serie jetzt irgendwann im Hintergrund so Meta-Gespräche über die Szene, die gerade geguckt wird. Der ist ja mega unscharf da vorne. Der Typ da vorne. Was hat der gerade gesagt? Ist der nicht in der Szene davor gestorben? Ja, die Serie fand ich gut. Hört bei Michi mit der Grund, ihr könnt doch jetzt nicht hier Plotter als... Kannst du dir bitte nicht so lautes Wasser einschenken, bitte? Viel Kohlenzauber. Nee, ein ganz authentisches Gespräch, einfach nur... Na ja, mal gucken. Grossartig. Ich glaube, ich kann diese Serie auch nicht richtig genießen. Ich auch nicht. Weil ich immer auf solche Details achten muss und mir immer denke, wie Stefan um drei Uhr nachts noch verzweifelt, sich überlegt, was steht auf dem Stundenplan, ey, Biochemie, aber was dann? Was sind voll, was sind Stunden drei? Wir fallen nur zwei Fächer ein. Aber dann muss man auch wirklich sagen, da habe ich gemerkt, die Jugend ist nicht mein Forte, wie die Jugend sagt. Das heißt, du musst jetzt hineinwachsen in die nächste Lebensphase. Was steht dir vor? Ich freue mich einfach auf Thais und freue mich da, was da kommt von dir. Thais muss jetzt echt die Jugend übernehmen. Ich meine, wir bräuchten jetzt vielleicht auch noch so ein paar Korrespondenten aus anderen Lebensbereichen, also irgendjemanden Senior, ja auch mal jemanden, der in ganz anderen Lebensrealitäten ist. Wir wollen in diesem Podcast alles verbinden. Ganz ehrlich, wir haben jetzt auch immer prominente Gäste gehabt, so was, oft Comedians oder so was. Lass uns doch da einfach mal andere nehmen, weil, also Anna Frebel zum Beispiel, mehr in diese Richtung. Ja, das stimmt. Oder ein Feuerwehrmann. Oder ich würde wahnsinnig gerne mal mit jemandem sprechen, der im Orchester spielt. Weil ich einfach mal wissen will, an so einem Orchesterabend, wie oft verspielt man sich da so? Und ist es nicht scheißegal? Oder kann ich zwei Geigen einfach sagen, heute Abend ist mir scheißegal, ich spiele einfach gar nicht. Du hast doch zehn. Also ich meine, ich glaube schon, dass ein guter Dirigent das vielleicht auch hören kann, wenn so vier Cellos sind und einer spielt kompletten Nonsens. Aber gerade bei einem Chor mit hundert Leuten, wo du einfach nur die Lippen bewegen kannst und mir kann niemand sagen, das will man eine Wette für Wetten das. Hundert Leute im Chor, einer singt nicht mit. Und irgendein Chorleiter oder irgendein krasser Musiktyp muss sagen, hier der. Aber musst du im Chor gut singen können eigentlich? Nee, ich glaube, du musst vor allem gut Skifahren können. Ich glaube, das ist vor allem... Ja, was denn sonst, Stefan? Du, ich bin frech heute drauf. Ja, frech, Anton Frechdachs. Nee, das gefällt mir nicht. Nee, ich meine jetzt, also das ist doch egal, wie du singst. Es kommt nur auf die Masse der Stimmen an. Die einzelnen Stimmen ist doch völlig egal. Ich würde sogar stören, wenn da jemand ein krasses Vibrato hat oder so. Du meinst so ein bisschen der Douglas-Effekt. So alle Düfte riechen dann auch wieder gleich zusammen. Wenn du alle Parfüms zusammen mischt, riecht es gleich. Aber riecht Stadtparfümerie Pieper genauso wie Douglas? Ich glaube schonetter. Rossmann hat auch einen DM-Beruch. Wetten, das Wetter, irgendwie Thomas Gottschalk fährt den Kandidaten in so einem Van in so einen Laden und sagt, wo sind wir gerade? Und dann sagt er, Billa. Nee, ganz falsch. Völlig falsch. Ganz falsch. Und dann 15 Minuten Fahrt woanders hin. Ja. Das war auch immer, das fand ich das Beste an Schlag den Raab, glaube ich. Dieses amateurhafte Wir gehen jetzt raus und sind auf Sendung. Die ganzen 10 Minuten Fußweg. Gab es nicht mal eine Sendung, wo das gesamte Publikum auch mitgegangen ist? Ich glaube, das war irgendwas anderes. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war. Also bei manchen Sendungen gab es, aber bei den Rat waren die aber auch manchmal draußen. Das stimmt schon auch. Aber ich fand es immer lustig, weil einfach, wir könnten Werbung machen, oder wir nehmen einfach den 10-Minuten-Fussweg mit. Und dann war irgendwann die Wahl, ja, wir gehen einfach jetzt und Elton muss sich eine Frage überlegen oder Stefan Rapp. Naja. War eine tolle Zeit. eine tolle Zeit. Also, ich habe einen Tipp bekommen, weil wir müssen ein bisschen aufräumen von der tollen Folge in Essen. Wir müssen uns wieder entschuldigen. Alle Leute, nee, nee, nee, nee. Alle Leute, die da waren, das war wirklich ein toller Abend. Es kam eine, eine Nachricht hat mich erreicht von Prikus Pictures. Und er schreibt mir auf Instagram. Hey Stefan, ich höre gerade euren aktuellen Podcast, lustigerweise beim Arbeiten. Ich bin zurzeit Elektriker. Jetzt könnt ihr euch schon denken, in welche Richtung es geht. Ich denke, ich habe eine Lösung für dein grelles Licht im Flur Problem. Für mich klingt es so, als hätte dein Licht eine viel zu hohe Wattzahl. So einfach ist es, denke ich. Die Lösung wäre zu berechnen, wie groß dein Flur ist. Er ist nicht groß. Hierzu ein Link. Wie? Zu einem Taschenrechner oder was? Oder einfach... Nee, LED-Lichtraum, Lichtraum-Lumen-Rechner. 2,5 Watt bei LEDs sind ungefähr 250 Lumen. Viel Erfolg, toller Podcast, du riechst daumen hoch. Ja, aber das ändert auch jetzt das Problem nicht, dass du diese Lampe auch nie wieder abmontieren kannst, weil du, wenn du dich zu nah ran näherst, einfach deine Augen weggebrannt werden und du nie wieder was sehen kannst. Du kannst sie doch nicht abmontieren. Wenn sie aus ist, ist es stockdunkel, wenn sie an ist, siehst du nichts mehr. Ich habe mir jetzt diese dimmbaren elektrischen WLAN-Leuchten bestellt, die man da auch reinschrauben kann. Dimmb? Ich finde, es klingt einfach wie ein Vornamen, wie Simba und Dumbo, die zusammen ein Kind kriegen. Dimba. Dimba. Er verschwindet immer leicht. Dimba. Dimba. Ja. Oh, übrigens. Dimba, Dimba, du. Eines der selten Wörter, die man so sagt, ist öffenbar. Also etwas öffenbar?
Erst etwas kann man, das Fenster ist öffenbar.
Ja, das ist, man kann das.
Das sagt man aber nicht.
Öfflich sagt, also nicht öfflich?
Öfflich?
Nein, das ist öfflich.
Das Fenster ist öfflich?
Das ist offenbar öffenbar.
Du kannst das Fenster öffnen, das ist öffenbar.
Hier stehen so viele Spiegel im Raum, Stefan, egal wo ich hinschaue, ich sehe nur dich.
Es ist wirklich, man kann die
gar nicht entfliehen.
Wollen wir den Rest des Podcasts nur
über den Spiegel? Es ist aber komisch, man sieht
ja anders aus über den Spiegel.
Du siehst deutlich attraktiv. What the fuck?
Du siehst in diesem Spiegel unglaublich attraktiv
aus? So gar nicht.
Aber jetzt hast du den Scheitel auf der anderen Seite,
das ist ganz merkwürdig. Es ist komisch. Ich finde es immer lustig, wenn man in der U-Bahn sitzt und dann guckt man raus und plötzlich hat man Blickkontakt mit dem gegenüber in dem Fenster. Das ist super. Und es ist immer unangenehm. Und dann gilt es, mein Zehn-Punkte-Plan wäre Punkt eins, Blickkontakt halten mit dem. Ja, ja. Weil das ist immer lustig. Ja, weil wenn du wegschaust, weiss die Person, dass du den Blickkontakt bemerkt hast. Du kannst ja immer so tun, als ob du einfach nur starren würdest oder einfach nur in die Ferne guckst. Weil um die Reflexion zu sehen, musst du ja auch scharf stellen auf die Ebene, wo das Glas ist. Du kannst ja das sehen, was hinter dem Fenster ist, du kannst aber auch auf die Reflexion fokussieren. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt, wie das funktioniert. Ja, mit Brennpunkt und so, Brennpunkt, Fokuspunkt. Nee, das ist mir schon klar, ich weiß noch nicht, das ist mir alles klar, was du gerade falsch gesagt hast, aber muss man doch den Spiegel scharf stellen, oder muss ich auf die Entfernung vom Spiegel zu dir jetzt scharf stellen, mit meinem Auge? Nee, auf die Entfernung zu mir, glaube ich. Ja, ich glaube nämlich auch. Weil sonst könntest du ja einfach alles scharf haben, wenn du nur ein Spiegel vor der NASA hast. Das ist ja meine Theorie, wenn man keine Brille trägt, aber in den Rückspiegel guckt, ob dann das Auto hinten trotzdem scharf ist, weil ich ja eigentlich nur zum Spiegel gucke. Ich glaube aber, so funktionieren Spiegelen. Es ist schwierig, es ist sehr kompliziert. Wir brauchen Optiker, wir brauchen einfach so einen richtigen, wir brauchen so einen Mikroskopenbauer, der einfach richtig Ahnung hat. Aber das Lustige ist, sucht mal Spiegel bei Ebay-Kleinanzeigen. Es ist unglaublich lustig. Es ist nicht so leicht, einen Spiegel zu fotografieren. Nein, und oft, also viel nachgeschoppt, Photoshop mit Weiss im Spiegel. Also den Fotografen selber rausgeschoppt. rausgeschoppt oder halt den kompletten Spiegelinhalt weiss. Das machen aber vor allem die professionellen Spiegel. Also den Fotografen selber rausgeschoppt. Oder halt den kompletten Spiegelinhalt weiss. Das machen aber vor allem die professionellen Spiegel-Shops, Spiegel24 und so. Und Spiegel Online, kennt man alles. Aber tatsächlich, die meisten haben einfach eine Hand, also viele Hände, die sich so reinschieben und man sieht viele Handys auch oder Leute, die sich in die Ecke stellen und versuchen, nicht auf dem Bild zu sein, aber dann grandios doch im Bild sind. Also ich kann darüber echt lachen. Das macht richtig Spaß, tatsächlich vielleicht für Feinschmecker auch noch. Schaut mal auf Ebay nach Besteck, nach Silberbesteck, das ja oft zu blank poliert ist, das ist auch stark reflektiert, aber da sind sich die Leute dem Problem nicht so bewusst. Bei dem Spiegel denkt man sich auch, shit, ja. Und es verformt. Also Spiegel zeigt einen ja, wie man ist. Aber Besteck sagt, ja, das ist dick. Aber du bist halt mit so einem Löffel und hast dann so ganz breit gezogene Augen. Backbäckchen. Und du denkst dir von dem Typen, ich kaufe mich jetzt eine Kabel. Riesige Bäckchen. Und dann macht er die Tür auf und sieht genauso aus. Der sieht genauso, genauso unförmigen Eierkopf.
Ah, die sind der von Ebay. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ich nehme die Löffel.
Ja, bitte.
Seine Frau sieht aus wie ein Messer, als wäre sie im Messer gespiegelt, sehr schlank und gross.
Hallo.
Ah, sehr gut.
Das ist ein guter Sketch.
Ja.
Ja, na ja.
Genau, aber sowas, damit beschäftige ich mich mittlerweile tagelang. Aber genau, worauf ich hinaus wollte, jemanden aus dem Orchester interviewen, fände ich wahnsinnig interessant. Auch wie aufgeregt die vor Konzerten sind oder ob das egal ist. Habt man eine gewisse Menge an Menschen. Ich habe gesehen, wir sind echt mittlerweile krasse Influencer, weil ich habe heute im Poster gesehen, ich weiß nicht mehr den genauen Wortlaut, aber inhaltlich hieß es, geh zum Zoll. Zoll ist eine feine Sache, geh zum Zoll. Go Zoll! Und das habe ich auch schon gesagt. Und ich glaube, der Zoll merkt plötzlich, stimmt, wir sind eigentlich gar nicht so scheiss, wir sind ganz geil. Und die hauen jetzt Werbung raus, geh zum Zoll. Geh zum Zoll. Und das ist grossartig. Und immer mehr Leute gehen zum Zoll, ich glaube, wir schaffen irgendwann Vollbeschäftigung, weil einfach alle zum Zoll gehen. Und das finde ich einfach wichtig, dass man da auch neue Berufsgruppen anspricht. Ja. Ich meine, irgendwie keine Ahnung, da gab es bestimmt Staaten, die gesagt haben, Shit, Mann, wir haben keine Bäcker. Und dann gesagt haben, werden jetzt einfach mal alle Bäcker. Ah, das ist eh spannend, dass sich das dann doch am Ende des Tages so gut aufteilt, oder? Also, dass Leute generationweise gehen von der Schule, machen während ihrer Schulzeit ähnliche Dinge, spielen Tennis, spielen abends Runde Fortnite, ich weiß, was die Jungsleute machen, hören Little Peep, gehen nächstes Tag in die Schule, haben schon eine Mathe und dann ist die Schule vorbei, irgendwann nach ein paar Jahren und Leute bilden eine Gesellschaft, die funktioniert. Das ist für mich ein Riesenrätsel, warum das nicht klar, hier und da hat man mal Fachkräftemangel, hier und da fehlt, sind Berufsgruppen, gibt es wenig Krankenschwestern, gibt es wenig Lehrer, aber am Ende des Tages funktioniert es doch ziemlich pralle, oder? Ich meine, wir haben jetzt, wie viel haben wir? Wir haben 400.000 Gymnasiasten, jetzt Abi geschrieben. Davon wollen 380.000 diese Fingerabdrucktypen werden, die Fingerabdrücke nehmen. Leute, das funktioniert so nicht. Ich weiss nicht, warum das gerade in diesem Jahr passiert, aber fast alle wollen diese Fingerabdruckleute werden, die mit dem Puder rumpudern.
Habt ihr einen Film gesehen?
Nee, ist einfach cool.
Ja, aber alle aus deuder herumpudern. Ja. Habt ihr einen Film gesehen oder? Nee, ist einfach
cool, also
ja, aber alle aus deiner Klasse, jede
einzelne, ihr habt unterschiedliche Leistungskurse,
wir wussten alle nicht, was wir machen wollten,
und dann hat der Lehrer in diesen Bildschirm reingeschoben,
und dann lief halt, welcher Bildschirm?
So ein Videobildschirm, da hat er halt
so ein Netflix-Doku angemacht.
Was ist ein Videobildschirm?
Er hat so einen Fernseher reingeschoben.
Okay.
Er hat diese dickeren Fernseher,
wie so ein Video-Bildschirm halt.
Er hat reingeschoben und wir haben bei Netflix-Doku
geguckt und dann gab es halt in einem Beruf
oder mit Puder. Er hat aber jetzt nicht gesagt,
hey, ich fände es gut, wenn ihr alle diese
Puder-Leute werdet. Er hat schon sowas gesagt.
Er hat es gesagt.
Rückblickend sah der auch nicht aus wie Lehrer, sondern wie der, der als eine Mädchen aus dem Fenster gefallen ist von uns neulich, der dann die Fingerabdrücke genommen hat. Rückblickend sah der so aus, mit dem Schnauzbart angeklebt. Also vielleicht war da Lobbyarbeit im Spiel. Wir wissen nicht, wie viele hundert Schulen der schon besucht hat. Entscheinen viele, wenn sie sagen, 400.000 Leute wollen das werden. Das ist schon eine Menge. Es gibt doch immer diese Berufsorientierungstests in Schulen. Und mir kann doch keiner erzählen, dass die echt sind. Ja, exakt. Die haben auf ihrem Zettel stehen, wir brauchen in dieser Schule noch zwei Zahnärzte, drei Bauingenieure und vier, die Billardtische bauen. Und dann sagen sie so, was sind denn deine Hobbys so? Magst du Mathe? Ja, Mathe mag ich gerne. Magst du Mathe? Und du arbeitest gerne mit Menschen? Physik mag ich auch gerne. Physik magst du auch? Ja, für Menschen arbeitest du gerne. Alles klar, gut. Also, deine Berechnung. Zahnarzt. Ah, hat er mir ausgespuckt. Welches Körperteil am Menschen interessiert dich am meisten? Ja. Also jetzt mal im Gesichtsbereich. Ja, dann Mund, würde ich sagen. Ja, okay, aber jetzt denk mal weiter. Wie, weiter? Denk mal weiter im Mund, also welcher Körperteil würde dich am meisten interessieren? Ja, dann würde ich sagen, weil man ja spricht und so, Zunge oder sowas. Naja, aber ich meine, wenn du jetzt was essen willst zum Beispiel, dann ist dir die Zunge nicht so wichtig. Nee, dann werden eher die Zähne wichtig. Die Zähne, alles klar, wunderbar, dann haben wir es doch hier. Zahnarzt. Du willst Zahnarzt werden. Next! Aber sowas bei mir auch. Klar, die wollen die beim Puschen. Und die gefragt, was machst du denn so in einer Freizeit? Sehr viel, also Musik zum Beispiel mache ich, ich bin, ich weiß nicht, interessiert für Unterhaltung und so und mache gerne Podcast, Radio und so was oder Theater AG. Ja, mach doch, mach doch Wirtschaftsingenieurwesen. Und dann habe ich herausgefunden, dass die tatsächlich so 50 Prozent aller Leute in dem Jahrgang gesagt haben, Wirtschaftsingenieurwesen. Die haben eine Quote. Ich glaube deswegen, dein Erstaunen ist völlig korrekt, aber es ist nicht natürlich. Aber lass uns das vielleicht mal. Das ist der Tim-Test gewesen bei uns, der Tim-Test, T-I-M-M. Können wir da vielleicht mal Thais hinschicken, um herauszufinden, ob da nicht ein bisschen Lobbyarbeit betrieben wird? Ey, das ist eine gute Idee. Weil ich glaube nämlich, dass die wirklich dem entgegenarbeiten wollen. Wir machen Folgendes, wir suchen uns einen Beruf für Thais aus. Aber was wollen wir damit erreichen? Warte, und schreiben alles auf, was man braucht, um perfekt in dem Beruf zu sein. Also jetzt sagen wir mal keine Ahnung, Schlangentrainerin. Und dann sagen wir, du hast keine Angst vor Schlangen. Hand-Augen-Koordination. Hand-Augen-Koordination, Resistenz gegen sämtliche Schlangengifte. Und diese zehn Eigenschaften geben wir ihr dann mit und sagen, ja, ich weiß irgendwie nicht, was ich machen will, aber das sind meine zehn Eigenschaften. Und dann müssten die ja eigentlich sagen Schlangentrainerin. Wenn die dann aber sagen, ja, Zoll, dann sagen sie, oh, oh, oh, oh, dann kommen wir durch die Tür gebrochen mit zwei Kamerateams. Die Tim-Test-Polizei kommt dann. Mit zwei Kamerateams und langen Holzstöcken und hauen einfach direkt auf die Hand drauf. Hey, wie hauen? Hauen dem einfach direkt auf die Hand drauf. Nein, nicht auf die Hand drauf.
Nein, wenn wir filmen, dann konfrontieren die dann nicht.
Dann drücken wir den so vom Stuhl runter,
hauen sie auf die Hände drauf.
Nein, wir fangen keine Gewalt.
Nee, das ist doch, und dann haben wir alles auf der Kamera.
Dann haben wir alles gefilmt.
Wie wir Gewalt anwenden.
Ja, und dann hauen wir das schon auf Instagram-Stories raus.
Nein, das ist strafbar.
40 Instagram-Stories mit ganz kleinen Augen. Du, wie du als Polizist. Fucking Tim-Test. Aber ich glaube, wenn man, wobei, ich muss sagen, Schlangenbissresistent, Giftresistent, da ist Zoll auch nicht so schlecht. Oh ja, stimmt. Oh, das ist eigentlich ein guter Punkt. Weil eigentlich das ist einer der zwei Jobs, wo man potenziell mit giftigen Schlangen zu tun hat. Das ist mein G-Stock. Das ist doch nicht Ihr G-Stock. Doch, das ist mein G-Stock. Kommen Sie mal mit in unser Zoll. Zum Glück bin ich giftimmun. Überall Schlangen. Das ist mein Billard-Kö. Buchstabieren Sie mal Kö. Ja, Kö, K-Ö. Sie haben mich. Verhaften Sie mich. Ach, buchstabieren wir mal KÖ. Q, U, E, U, E. Q, U, E, U, E? Q, U, E, U, E. Q, U, E. Q, U, E. Q, U, E. Ich glaube schon. Französisch ist schon absurd. Ist das Französisch? Dachtest du Dänisch, also Billard kommt das nicht aus Dänemark? Nee, dann wäre es einfach das durchgestrichene Ö, äh, O, wo sie sagen, O, ne. Ich glaube, die haben das so mit Kanonenkugeln gespielt, Billard, am Anfang. Die haben dann so... Und Kö heisst ja übersetzt Kanonen. Stogge, Stängel. Ich glaube, wenn du da auf so einer Festung bist mit fünf Kanonen... Kö ist französisch für Schlange. Das ist der absurdeste Bogen, den wir jemals ... Aber wie schreibt man Kö? Ah! Q ist ja auch Schlange. Ach so. Kö ist französisch Schlange, Stiel, Schwanz. Hä, Moment mal, das ist jetzt der krasseste Zufall aller Zeiten. Ja. Ja, stimmt, Q. Ja. I have no Q. Bei Mr. Bond? Mit Dr. Q? Irgendwie ist so ein Punkt erreicht im Podcast, wo man sagt, holy shit, also es hat gerade sehr viele Storylines. So einer von der Matrix reinkommen und sagen, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, sorry, das soll so nicht passieren. Ihr seid da im Gespräch falsch abgebogen. Ja, das ist wie wenn du in so einem Spiel so durch die Hauswand glitscht und dann so hinten. Das gibt es ja bei World of Warcraft immer.
Wo man dann kurz schon hinten in der Endlösung, in der Epocheliga ist.
In der Endlösung?
Äh, Epocheliga meine ich.
Ups, da bin bin kurz versprochen.
Ich war...
Äh, äh, äh, äh, Poki-Lieger.
Rette dich, rette dich.
Halt dich an irgendwas fest, was dir gerade einfällt.
Irgendein anderes Wort, Bananenkrug. Ich glaube, das gesamte Dritte Reich war eine Aneinanderreihung von Versprechern, da kommt man nicht mehr raus, da muss man ran. Nee, ich wollte tatsächlich irgendwas, es war eine Mischung aus Komplettlösung und Ende des Spiels, dann kam das bei raus. Okay, und warum Juden, alle Juden ins Gas, was war das? Das habe ich gerade nur, da war ich mich schon verrannt. Du meintest Top 4, Indigo-Plateau eigentlich. Ups, ähm, was hat mit? Bei World of Warcraft, da gibt es ja Spielleiter sozusagen, so Mitarbeiter von Blizzard, die aufpassen, dass die Spieler nichts Dummes machen. Und wenn du dich halt dann so durchglitscht durch so einen Berg. Sind das die, die da stehen manchmal am Rand von den Bauern? Nee, nee, nee, die sind unsichtbar. Ist das der Bauer am Feld, der sagt, befreie mein Feld von den fünf Hunden. Und du so, fick dich, du dummer Bauer, und der so, ey, hallo, ich bin ein echter Mensch. Entschuldigung, ich bin von Blizzard? Oh, sorry, scheiße. Ich bin von Blizzard, ich arbeite nicht so viel. Nee, da gibt es ganz viele Legenden drum und die sind immer unsichtbar und niemand weiß, wo die sind. Und manchmal machen die sich aber auch sichtbar, wenn die mit Leuten reden und dann so, ich stand schon die ganze Zeit neben dir. Und so, krass. Und die schreiben dich dann auch manchmal an, wenn du halt so dich durch so einen Berg glitscht und irgendwo hingehst, wo du nicht sein darfst. Und die schreiben dann so, ah, wo willst du hin? Sind die in den Berg die ganze Zeit oder was? Weiß man nicht. Die sind halt so Admins, die sehen alles, was alle Spieler machen und so. Und dann sagst du halt so, oh, jetzt habe ich mich verlaufen, aber, oh, jetzt ist aber komisch gerade. Soll ich dich zurückbringen? Nö, nö, nö, nö, ich bin selbst hier raus. Ich bring dich mal zurück. Wir porten dich irgendwo hin. Och geil.
Reden die mit dir auch?
Ja, die reden auch mit mir.
Ich hab mich schon mal lange mit jemandem gestritten, weil ich mein, du spielst ja das Spiel.
Und dann waren wir in einem Raid mit 25 Spielern und dann kam halt gerade der Endboss.
Und wir waren halt gerade im Endboss-Kampf.
Und das weiß der Game-Meister auch.
Und der hat mich angeschrieben, ja, du wegen dem verlorenen Gegenstand hast du kurz Zeit zu schreiben.
Und ich halt so, nee, wir kämpfen gerade gegen Magtheridon.
Und der so, ja, ich hab aber nur kurz Zeit.
Ich bin ein Kind. auch. Und der hat mich angeschrieben, ja, du, wegen dem verlorenen Gegenstand hast du kurz Zeit zu schreiben. Und ich halt so, nee, wir kämpfen gerade gegen Magteridon. Und der so, ja, ich habe immer nur kurz Zeit. Ja, aber du siehst doch, dass ich gerade gegen den Boss käme. Und der so, ja, dann musst du später nochmal schreiben. Aber wenn jemand verstehen müsste, dass man dann nicht kann. Eben! Das ist doch wie so eine Mutter. Genau so, kannst du es nicht kurz pausieren? Ja, nein, B.O.W. kann man nicht pausieren. Wie so eine Mom, die mit einem spricht, aber wenn es jemand wissen müsste, dann der Bitterweil von Blizzard. Also ganz merkwürdig, aber vielleicht wollte sie auch nur rausreden, keine Ahnung. Das Coolste an Spielen fand ich immer, zum Beispiel bei GTA, wenn man ein Taxifahrer sein kann oder ein Krankenwagenfahrer, wenn man einen Job, wenn man plötzlich so ein Minigame daraus macht und so ein eigenes Spiel spielt. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist eigentlich das Beste im echten Leben. Warum gibt es das nicht zum Beispiel? Dass man sagen kann, wenn du Bock hast, da dachte ich immer, das wäre die Idee von Uber, dass wenn du gerade Zeit hast, kannst du Taxifahrer sein. Kannst du so tun, als wäre du ein Taxifahrer. Kannst du einfach mal Taxifahrer sein. Oder wenn du gerade mal Zeit hast und Bock hast, Leute anzurufen, sei mal kurz ein Callcenter. Ja. Sei mal kurz jemand, der Werbung macht für ein weirdes Medikament und muss Leute, also wie diese weirden Firmen, die ein bisschen auch illegal sind, wo man halt Leute anrufen muss die ganze Zeit. Ja, ja. Schickt mit ein paar Nummern, also so ganz kurz ang, ganz kurz angestellt ist. Ja. Dafür fände ich geil so eine App. Du hast mal kurz eine Stunde Zeit und kannst Geld verdienen in der Stunde, indem du ganz kurz für ein seltsames Callcenter arbeitest. Tatsächlich habe ich das mal gemacht. Im Callcenter, weiss ich das. Nee, nee, nee, pass auf. Und zwar, ich dachte wohl mit meinem Leben, ich zog den ganzen Tag World of Warcraft, das wird nix. Und hab dann die Welt der Micropayments für mich entdeckt. Micropayments ist eine Welt, in der man wirklich kleinste und winzigste Aufgaben erledigen kann für Minimalsbezahlungen. Du willst mir gerade sagen, dass diese weirte Gedanken, die ich gerade hatte, schon Realität sind? Und zwar gehst du dann auf eine Webseite und da gibt es dann eine Million Bilder und Bilder von einem Code, also ein abfotografierter Code. Und deine Aufgabe ist es, den Code einzutippen, also halt einfach zu digitalisieren, was Google heute automatisch macht, ging damals halt noch nicht vor zehn Jahren. Das heißt, du siehst da halt 583, hat jemand ein Foto gemacht und du schreibst-3 in das Feld und kriegst dafür einen Cent. Du kriegst pro Code einen Cent. Und erst mal, als mit meinem 16-jährigen Gehirn damals den ganzen W-W-Zock, dachte ich mir, ja geil, da mache ich das halt ein paar Stunden am Tag. Aber irgendwann arbeitest du halt eine Stunde und du denkst dir, ja gut, wie viel habe ich jetzt in einer Stunde geschafft? 200, 200 Cent, zwei Euro in einer Stunde. Und dafür bin ich halt komplett brei im Hirn, weil ich die ganze Zeit Fenster auf eingetippt, Fenster auf eingetippt, so. Du wirst halt völlig bescheuert, aber das Geil an dem System ist, und jetzt pass auf, wenn du Aufgaben erfüllst, wirst du höher gerankt als sozusagen der kann was, oder der ist zumindest mal ein Mensch. Das ist auch gut. Und dann kriegst du vielleicht besser verdiente Aufgaben. Zum Beispiel müssen oft Leute ihre Website testen. Und dann schicken die Links ihre Website und die scannen halt deinen Bildschirm, was du machst. Also wo deine Cursor hingeht, was für offene Fragen hast oder halt so, worauf du klickst. Und die sagen dann einfach hier ist die Website, bestelle mal dieses Produkt. Und dann gehst du auf die Website und musst halt gucken, wo findest du das Produkt. Und dann können die halt genau gucken, ah, der findet sich ja noch nicht zurecht und so. Ist es benutzerfreundlich oder nicht, genau. Genau, und dafür kriegst du dann halt mal einen Euro. Oh. Und dann denkst du dir, ja gut, wenn ich das jetzt hier zehn in der Stunde mache. Ja, dann heil mal hier Krebs. Ja. Und irgendwann ist man dann so einer, ja, jetzt kann ich auch nicht mehr helfen. Und das ist echt krass, weil ich dachte mir wirklich, ich dachte bestimmt ein halbes Jahr meines Lebens, so werde ich meinen Lebensunterhalt verdienen. Wirklich immer so einen kleinen Scheiss machen. Das ist ein halbes Jahr gebraucht, bis du gemerkt hast, dass es so nicht klappen wird. Und ich hatte, glaube ich, in einem halben Jahr hatte ich dann so 14 Euro verdient oder so. Vier Euro. Und habe mir die dann auszahlen lassen und dachte mir, das ist ehrlich verdientes Geld. Aber es ist eine krasse Welt und eigentlich die grösste Zeitverschwendung, die man kann. Weil hol den normalen Job, da kriegst du Mindestlohn und dann ist dein Arbeitsergebiet auch zu Ende. Aber an sich ist es eine coole Welt, weil du hast halt so das Gefühl, du bist komplett selber Herr über deinen Arbeitsergebiet. Es ist halt so eine First-World-Art. Ich meine halt, Langeweile zu bekämpfen mit jetzt was zu tun und da kommst du ja gar nicht auf die Summe an, auf das Geldverdienen, aber erst mal so die zwei Stunden, die man hat, nutzen, um Taxi zu fahren, was nicht funktioniert wegen Personenbeförderungsgesetz und so, aber dann vielleicht wieder mal Leute anzurufen und denen Aspirin zu empfehlen. Warte mal, ich überlege gerade, weil ich habe dann auch noch lange während der Masterclass war ich auf so einer Website, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie die heisst, aber da musste man sich Trailer anschauen, zu filmen. Und für jeden Trailer hast du fünf Cent bekommen. Aber manchmal auch welche für zehn. Und dann hast du einfach den Trailer angeguckt und damit die wissen, dass du den wirklich angeguckt hast, hast du am Ende eine Frage gestellt bekommen. Wie, keine Ahnung, der Mörder tötet ihn mit einem Messer, Pistole, Seil. Und dann musst du die richtig beantworten. Die waren total leicht, aber dadurch stell dir halt sicher, dass du es wirklich anguckst. Und das habe ich wirklich, während mir Frank Elzer, der irgendwas gelabert hat, habe ich ständig Trailer angeguckt und da habe ich locker auch nochmal irgendwie zehn Euro mitgemacht über einen Monat. Ist halt lächerlich, aber du denkst dir halt so, bevor ich jetzt halt gar nichts mache, verdiene ich halt fünf Cent und schau mir halt Trailer an. Und wenn du dich für Filme interessierst, ist es gar nicht so doof, zu wissen, was so gerade läuft und was es so gibt. Schaust dir die ganzen Trailer an. Klingt alles ein bisschen nach Marktforschung. Ich habe bei MacroParents gegoogelt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es das heute überhaupt noch gibt oder ob das heute komplett Indien einfach macht oder irgendwie, ob man das komplett auslagert oder einfach durch Computer
mittlerweile einfach alles möglich ist.
Aber es war eine wilde Zeit,
war eine wilde Zeit damals.
Ja, schon interessant,
das muss aber im Internet eigentlich jetzt immer mehr
existieren oder nicht, weil gefühlt
existieren immer grössere
Plattformen und immer grössere Menschenmassen
und irgendwie
ich schätze ich mal, es ist schon cool, auch gerade für die, die dann halt wirklich einen Code transkribiert haben wollen oder sowas. Ja, ja. Ich meine, es ist halt die Frage, ob das nicht alles auch Bots machen können. Also gerade so stupide Aufgaben wie Audio transkribieren und so. Gerade mit den Bildern, da hast du schon recht. Das ist mit den Bildern ist ja kein Problem mehr. Das ist mittlerweile einfach kein Problem mehr. Wobei ich glaube, es macht Google ja auch mit den Captures, wo man dann sagt, klick auf alle Bilder, die ein Auto haben. Da hilft man denen ja auch gerade mit so Erkennungsmerkmalen. Aber wahrscheinlich haben die in drei Jahren genug Daten, dass es dann halt einfach ein Auto wird. Aber ich muss sagen, wenn du da knallhart mal ein Auto nicht anklickst, dann, also bei mir ist der Capture ziemlich hart. Ja, aber vor allem sagt er dann nicht, klicken sie alle Bilder mit einem Straßenschild an und dann klickst du eins falsch an und dann sagt er, nee, falsch. Dann sagst du, ja, wer testet hier gerade wen? Ja. Also wenn du ja schon weißt, was es ist, warum machen wir es dann? Moment mal kurz, ich habe in dem Podcast gehört, dass du mich testest. Wie ich zahle dir Geld, Google? Moment. Aber ich finde vor allem die Frage ein bisschen misleading, weil klicken Sie auf alle Bilder, wo ein Strassenschild zu sehen ist. Ja, stimmt. Schrengenommen ist die Ecke eines Strassenschildes. Manchmal ist da nur so ein roter Fleck, zwei rote Pixel auf einem Bild. Ja, und was ist mit dem Stiel? Ja, genau. Also dem Ständer der Stange. Ist das Teil des Strassenschildes? Das ist Teil des Strassenschildes. Aber wenn es das Bild wäre, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, das ist ein Strassenschild zu sehen. Aber man will sich auch nicht anlegen mit Google in dem Moment, weil man ja danach will ja erstmal beweisen, dass man kein Roboter ist. Und man denkt sich auch, würde ein Roboter jetzt nicht die Frage stellen, ob das Teil des Strassenschildes ist. Von daher, man will sich nicht anlegen. Es ist eine verrückte Welt, aber wir leben in einer verrückten Welt, das muss man schon auch einfach sagen. Ja, im Endeffekt. Mittlerweile ist es ja so, dass im April ist ein grosses Spiel, wo ein Dota-Team spielt gegen eine KI. Also die halt so auch durch so verschiedene Learning und so. Gab es das nicht schon mal? Haben sie auch schon mal gemacht, aber die spielen jetzt Dota hat ja immer fünf Spieler und die spielen jetzt wirklich in Fünfer-Teams auch. Also so eins gegen eins haben die schon gemacht. Gegen fünf KIs oder gegen eine KI? Das ist halt jetzt eine Definitionsfrage, aber das ist schwer zu sagen. Ja. Die sagen dann auch so, ich hab gut gespielt, aber der Bot 3 hat sich das Scheiße gebaut. Der kann nix! Der Microsoft-Typ. Hey! Ich bin auch Teil! Aber es ist sehr spannend, aber es ist schon komisch. Ich finde nicht, dass es Spaß macht, bei Spielen zuzuschauen, wenn man weiß, der Gegner ist eine Maschine. Wenn zwei menschliche Mannschaften gehen und spielen, macht es viel mehr Spaß, zuzuschauen, weil wenn der halt dann dreimal im Kreis läuft und gegen den Baum läuft die ganze Zeit und sie trotzdem das Spiel gewinnen und irgendwie hat man dann nicht die Emotionen dahinter, das ist ganz komisch.
Ja, obwohl dir ja streng genommen das bessere Spiel siehst wahrscheinlich.
Also jetzt mal rein objektiv im strategischen Sinne.
Siehst du ja wahrscheinlich das interessanteste, genau wie dieses Go-Spiel, das asiatische Brettspiel,
wo dann auch danach viele Experten total beeindruckt waren von dieser intuitiven Spielweise der KI. Aber jetzt denken wir das doch mal nochmal 10, 20 Jahre weiter. Wir denken mal weiter. Was hält denn, also die werden ja immer besser, die Go-Rechner. Was hält denn jetzt irgendwie so ein Go-Profi davon ab? Du hast so ein Mikrochip, in 20 Jahren sind die halt so groß wie eine rote Blutzelle oder sowas. Das Ball ballerst du dir ins Ohr, der sagt dir den nächsten Move und du spielst halt nur noch mit deiner KI. Also du spielst selber gar nicht mehr. Nur noch mit deiner KI und dann schluckst du halt irgendwas runter, was du halt nicht messen kannst. Das war mal eine Kurzfilmidee von mir. Sorry, dass ich immer wieder nicht da rein... Ja genau, auch mit Go, nein, dass man quasi in den Laden geht und man sieht erst nicht, es sieht erst aus wie ein Saturn, wo ein Mädchen vor so einem ... Am Big Park Placement-Deal? Nee, aber es ist einfach, dass man denkt, das ist ein neues Regal und es sind so coole Verpackungen irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die so aussehen wie, ich weiß nicht, wie so Wii-Spiele oder so ein Playstation-Spielregal. Und dann nimmt sie sich was und zeigt sie ihrer Mutter und sie sagt, nee, ist zu teuer und legt zurück.
Und es war einfach die Fähigkeit für Geige spielen.
Und dann kommt raus, dass alle Menschen in ihrem Nacken so ein, wenn sie wollen, und sie hat das noch nicht das Mädchen,
aber dann geht sie mit ihrer Mutter zum Orchester oder so, holt sich ein Stück an und das ganze Orchester hat hinten, haben alle Spieler so ein Loch, weil man sich das implantieren kann am Kopf und alle, bei jedem blinkt halt dieses Software und alle haben sich ihr Instrument gekauft. Man kann halt in diese Läden gehen, wo du alles hast, und da steht drüber halt Naturwissenschaften, und dann kannst du dir Physik kaufen, irgendwie Quantenmechanik oder so, keine Ahnung.
Fand ich schon ganz cool, einfach so ein Gedankenexperiment. Und wie uncool es wäre, einem Orchester zuzuschauen, wo alle sich die Software für ihr Instrument runtergeladen hätten. Und auch beim Dirigenten blinkt es hinten am Kopf, wo man weiß, okay, jetzt ist es auch gekauft. Und wie es sofort den Wert verlieren würde, weil es sofort die Menschlichkeit verliert und damit erregt sich einen Anspruch von Kunst irgendwie.
Ich meine, Stephen Hawking hatte ja gegen Ende seines Lebens...
Dankeschön für die Kritik.
Der gegen Ende seines Lebens so einen Rollstuhl, wo er nur noch denken musste, wohin er fahren will.
Der musste das nicht mehr mit seinem Körper kontrollieren, sondern er denkt vorwärts und fährt vorwärts.
Was ist, wenn er eigentlich diesen Donut will, aber er weiss, er kann nicht, weil du Diabetes und die andere AES. Der Stuhl weiss, was er am besten will. Mit dem Kompass von Jack Sparrow. Das muss doch dann auch andersrum gehen, dass du einen Chip im Computer hast, der dir das Signal gibt, vorwärts. Also dass du dann sozusagen gedanklich die Information verpackst. Musst du denn vorwärts denken? Musst du denkenwärts? Du musst denken vorwärts. Also es ist halt schwer, sich das vorzustellen, aber du kannst ja auch denken, jetzt mach mal jetzt voran hier. Hand hoch heim. Links, rechts, das kann man schon denken, abstrakt. Aber das muss ja dann auch andersrum gehen. Und dann kann dir jemand einen Chip einfach ins Gehirn ballern, der halt dann dir sagt, welchen Go-Zug du als nächstes machen kannst. Kann er auch denken. Oder dass du dann selber denkst, es sei deine eigene Entscheidung gewesen. Und dann irgendwann, warum soll das denn, ist halt so wie Intellektuellen, dann ist gar nicht mehr Doping das Problem bei körperlichen Sportarten, sondern vor allem bei so mentalen Sportarten. Schach ist komplett gedopt, alle ballern sich so ein Elektrochip rein und dann irgendwann stirbt die Sportart aus, weil alle sagen, ja Leute, am Ende spielt die Karin noch gegen sich selbst. Aber selbst so Sportarten wie Fechten oder so können wir vorstellen,, dass man tendenziell schon den Gegner analysieren kann und gucken, was der beste Zug wäre. Aber es stimmt. Man kann Steve Hawking auch denken, ich brauche einen schlagfertigen Witz, schlagfertigen Witz, kommen zwei Männer in eine Bar. Ich glaube, er hat es versucht. Wenn du so einen Stuhl hast, der auf deine Gedanken hört, dann sagst du Flieg, flieg los,
flieg mich hier raus,
flieg zum Mond, flieg, flieg.
Und du denkst selber mal gucken, was passiert.
Und die Ingenieure im Labor so, was macht
der denn da? Der hebt
ab.
Und dann sind Sterne
im Himmel.
Tschau, Steven, tschau!
Das ist ja die
weirdeste Pokémon-Folge aller Zeiten.
Stimmt, das war die Folge, die
Die Himmel. Bling! Ja. Ciao, Steven! Ciao! Das ist ja die weirdeste Pokémon-Folge aller Zeiten. Stimmt, das war die Folge, die ich nicht mochte. Die mit der Endlösung, als Ash kennt schon die ganze Zeit von der Endlösung gesprochen. Es war schon komisch. Wobei, man muss sagen, was passiert denn mit den Pokémon? Du bringst die ins Pokécenter, dann geht die, diese mysteriöse Frau, Gerti, Gerti Pokécenter, geht hinten, im Lager gucken, und dann blinkt es kurz, man sieht nur helle Lichter hinten aus dem Lager kommen, lustige Melodie, aber grelles Licht, und dann kriegst du Pokémon wieder. Woher kommen die wieder? Das sind doch nicht deine. Das sind nicht deine. Ich glaube nicht, dass es deine. Da gab es eine Endlösung. Die werden halt direkt geklont. Die werden umgebracht, geklont und wieder sozusagen in guter Verfassung. Du meinst wie im Christopher-Nollen-Film Prestige. Oder wie in Moon. Nee. Spoiler. Oh, das ist echt ein Spoiler. Oh, das sollte man nicht tun. Den kennt nicht jeder. Na ja, Leute. Da würde ich piepen. Wobei, das ist eine gute Frage, ab wann, wir dürfen ja über Filmenden ja wohl sprechen. Du, ich hab, mir sind Spoiler sowieso völlig egal. Ich weiß einfach nur, dass viele Leute sehr sensibel sind, was Film angeht. Darf man Dokumentation spoilern? Da habe ich mich gefragt. Du, ich schau gerade... Ich fand es total uncool bei Leaving Neverland, dass sie die ganze Zeit schon wusste, worauf es hinausläuft. Warum, war es okay, bei Dokumentationen zu spoilern und bei Filmen nicht? Du, ich habe mich echt geärgert. Ich schaue gerade die Netflix-Dokuserie über dieses verlorene Mädchen. Madeline McCann. Madeline McCann, genau. Ja, das habe ich auch geschaut. Die Serie geht los mit zwei Telefonnummern. Wenn sie irgendwas über Madeline wissen, rufen sie an, wo ich mir denke, oh Leute, ich weiss doch schon, dass sie nicht gefunden wird. Nee, das fand ich total gut. Nee, das macht man am Ende der ersten Folge. Das ist ja kein Witz. Nee, deinen Witz gerade, den Witz, den du gemacht hast. Ich dachte, der ist ein Witz von dir, weil es ist natürlich super geschmacklos, damit zu spielen, dass gerade ein Mädchen, was gerade noch weg ist, finde ich super geschmacklos, das damit als dramaturgisches Mittel umzugehen. Nee, aber mach's von mir aus ... Ich finde es supergut, direkt klarzumachen, hey, hier geht's um Mädchen, was noch nicht gefunden wurde. Ja, aber mach das doch am Ende der ersten Folge zum Beispiel. Was, nein, aber das kommt doch die meisten gar nicht. Niemand kommt bis zum Abspann bei Netflix. Aber die ganze Serie heißt es dann, oh, war's der Nachbar, war's der Nachbar, und du denkst dir, nee, war's nicht. Wir wissen schon, dass der nicht gefunden wurde, sonst würden die diese Doku nicht machen. Also ich weiß, du hast natürlich recht geschmackvoll und so, es ist geschmackvoll, das klingt einfach nicht schmacklos in dem Kontext. Also lecker wäre es natürlich gewesen, so zu machen wie du. Schmackhaft, es war richtig schmackhaft, aber es ist die köstlichste Lösung. Gemüsslich, kann man auch sagen. Klar, es wird so zu machen, aber tolle Dokus, schaut es euch an, Madeleine McCann. Ich fand die auch ganz interessant. Aber so weird, ey, mit den Hunden alleine, da bin ich ausgestiegen irgendwann. Das fand ich richtig spannend. Ich fand es richtig albern, dass die halt einfach jeden Typen verdächtig haben, der dann mal rumläuft in dieser Stadt, der nicht da eh wohnt, sondern halt vielleicht einfach zu Besuch ist und dann jeder einfach hochgenommen wird und dann das beste, Spoiler, fuck it, mir wurde auch gesagt, dass Michael Jackson Kinder... Spoiler sind köstlich, hast du gerade gesagt. Spoiler sind köstlich, vor allem Dokus. Vor allem hat dann plötzlich ja, haben dann die Eltern ja irgendwann,
Metro Tres, diese krassen Detektive aus Madrid eingestellt, die einfach angefangen haben, die gleichen Leute, die schon mal verdächtigt wurden, die wieder freigelassen wurden, noch mal zu verdächtigen. Und dann haben die einfach so deren Auto angezündet. Und man auch sagt, Leute, um die unter Druck zu setzen, wo ist Maddy, Auto angezündet. Und diese arme Russe, der da hergezogen ist und ein normales Leben leben wollte, hat plötzlich sich von einem brennenden Auto. Du denkst dir, was ist mir wichtiger, mein Auto oder dass die gesamte Welt denkt, dass ich ein vierjähriges Mädchen entführt habe. Also was ist denn das für ein Deal? Absurd, aber wirklich spannende Doku, auch was, was, was, dass es so ein Kreislauf ist, auch was Medien dann wiederum mit dem Fall an sich machen und für den Einfluss haben. Auch spannend, dass es in Portugal so krasse andere Gesetze gibt, wie zum Beispiel in England. In Portugal ist sie verschwunden, da war die Engländerin. Die englischen Eltern sind in Urlaub gefahren in Portugal, da ist sie verschwunden. Und gerade in England und Portugal, es kann glaube ich in Europa nicht diametral entgegengesetzte Richtlinien geben, wie man mit der Polizei spricht, als Medienkonzern oder einfach Zeitung, aber einfach als Journalist. Und da ist es interessant, wie auch die Eltern damit gezwungen werden, umzugehen, gerade weil in England oder in den USA muss man ja vor die Presse treten als Eltern. In Deutschland ist es nicht üblich zum Beispiel, absurd sogar, in Portugal war es auch absurd. Wir sind ja auch trotzdem vor das Hotel gegangen und haben gesagt, unsere Tochter fehlt. Das ist weg. Grossartig, schaut es euch an. Es ist auch sehr lustig, weil die Eltern und generell die Sudoku auch harte Kritik an der portugiesischen Polizei üben. Und eine der allerlustigsten Szenen für mich ist, wo sie sagen, Madeleine wurde entführt, die Polizei ist informiert, die ersten Stunden sind extrem wichtig, weil der Entführer verlässt halt jetzt gerade Zeit. Und die Polizei kam nach vier Stunden. Die Polizei kam nach vier Stunden und dann zeigen sie auch so ein Polizeiauto am Rand der Straße, wo sie sagen, hier sind vier Polizisten, sie sassen vierzig Minuten lang nur in ihrem Auto und währenddessen fahren ganz viele Autos vorbei und dann zeigen sie so ein Van mit dunklen Scheiben und verfolgen ihn so mit der Kamera und dann halt implizieren, wahrscheinlich ist sie da drin und dann siehst du halt die vier Polizisten, die einfach nur in ihrem Auto sitzen und gar nichts machen.
Da war Madeline!
Und es ist so lustig, dass dieses Kamerateam lieber dieses Auto filmt, wo die vier Leute drin sind, wo nichts passiert und dann sagen sie, 40 Minuten lang machen sie gar nichts.
Sassen nur im Auto. Sassen zu viert im Auto und machen nichts. Was machen die denn
zu viert im Auto, 40 Minuten lang?
Ich fand es grossartig.
Und vor allem der beste Satz,
wirklich grossartig,
wurde dann die Mutter interviewt von dem
Kommissar da und dann meinte
der Kommissar halt so Routinefrage,
waren sie denn schon mal in Portugal?
Und die Mutter antwortet, nein
und ich werde auch nie wieder kommen. Wo sie denkt so, okay, sorry, jetzt ist das ganze Land scheiße, weil deine Tochter entführt wurde. Also wirklich so ein Customer-Review, der sagt so, ne, ich, wenn man sich beschwert... Zwei von fünf Sternen. Hotel war gut, Tochter weg, zwei von fünf Sternen. Tochter weg, mich seht ihr hier nie wieder. Tatsächlich habe ich über diesen Satz auch lange nachgedacht. Weil, ähm, und dann habe ich auch oft über Mentalität und Temperament nachgedacht. Mhm. Und, äh, also zum, ich verstehe diesen Satz total. Aus einer, ich bin gerade aufgebracht, meine Tochter ist gerade weg, ähm, jemand fragt mich, eine belanglose Frage, wie, wie gefällt es Ihnen in Portugal?
Und das ist das Land, was ich gerade primär mit dem Tod oder zumindest mit dem Verschwinden meiner Tochter verbinde. Und dann sowas zu sagen wie, also weil die Doku hat zu dem Zeitpunkt darauf angespielt, dass die Polizei die ab dem Zeitpunkt gehasst hat. Richtig, ja. Und dann dachte ich mir, das ist natürlich interessant, weil von Eltern natürlich in solchen Situationen man nicht erwarten kann, wirklich reflektiert zu sprechen. Und natürlich sagt man quatschige Dinge. Ja, total. Aber auf seiner Seite musst du die Professionalität als Polizeier haben, das zu reflektieren und das nicht jetzt irgendwie das Nationalstolzgefühl verletzen. Ja gut, aber einerseits ist es natürlich albern, generell einem Land als solchen Schuld an irgendwas zu geben, aber dann auch einfach zu sagen, wir sind jetzt unsere Schuld oder was. Also wenn der portugiesischen Polizei, die eh schon, also ich hätte nicht, also ich habe da keine Ahnung, wie Polizeiarbeit funktioniert, aber ich finde es eh spannend, dass eine ausländische Polizei überhaupt so intensiv diesen Fall aufnimmt und dann da macht. Das ist schon krass. Und so, und dass sie, ja, lasst ihr eure Polizei machen. Aber gut, klar, wenn es da passiert ist,
Verbrechen ist es natürlich auch deren Problem.
Ich habe mir wieder meine eigenen Theorien, ich habe zu allen
diesen Logos immer meine eigenen Theorien.
Und für mich war die plausibelste, also erstmal
ist es ja schon seltsam, dass diese
ganzen Elternfreundschaftsgruppe,
die dann da in diesem Restaurant saß
und ich habe mit vielen Leuten, ich wusste nicht,
die waren in der Tapas-Bar.
Und dann waren, zehn Minuten weiter weg, war das angeblich mit Blickkontakt einzusehende Apartment. Wo auch fragwürdig ist, ob das so einsehbar war. Gut. Und dann sind die alle 20 Minuten aufgestanden und haben ihre Kinder gecheckt. Ich fand das schon seltsam. Weil das Ganze ... Erst mal finde ich es komisch, die Kinder alleine zu lassen. Da habe ich mal meine Mutter gefragt zum Beispiel, ob man das macht, weil ich konnte das nicht einschätzen. Aber das ist interessant, weil ich dachte mir nämlich, der Punkt wird auch in der Doku aufgeworfen, wo Leute sagen so, wo dann irgendwie eine andere empörte Mutter in England sagt, ich würde meine Kinder niemals alleine lassen und essen gehen, wo ich mir dachte, ja selbstverständlich. Aber doch nicht so weit weg. Naja komm, das ist ein Gegenüber des Pools bei der Urlaubsanlage. Die älteste Tochter war drei, die anderen waren echt jünger und ich sag mal so eine dreijährige Tochter, die macht das schon mal Quatsch oder so, also die schläft ja nicht durch, Kinder schlafen ja auch nicht durch, ich find's schwierig. Also ich fand, ihr war unterschiedliche Anhängensweisen, aber ich fand's völlig selbstverständlich, dass die Eltern einfach mal sagen, komm wir packen es. Und den spannendsten Punkt, ich habe mich die ganze Zeit gefragt, bis es eben angesprochen wurde, als dann die Mutter gecheckt hat und verstanden hat, das Kind ist weg, hat die geschrien, das Apartment durchwühlt und hat die, ist rausgerannt, hat die anderen Leute geholt. Ja. Wo waren zu dem Zeitpunkt die beiden Geschwisterkinder? Die haben geschlafen. So, und die haben die ganze Zeit durchgepennt. Ja. Und dann Da dachte ich mir, weißt du was, der Vater war ja sogar Arzt. Er ist Arzt. Und ich dachte mir, ja, natürlich, der hat einfach schön so ein Beteiligungsmittel reingeballert, dass die die ganze Nacht durchschlafen, dann würde ich mich auch so voll in den Tapas-Bar setzen. Und es wäre mir scheißegal. Wenn ich wüsste, wie man das dosiert und sagt, okay, ihr kriegt ein bisschen was zum Schlafen, damit ihr schön durchschlaft, wir nicht gestört werden und so, dann verstehe ich auch, warum die alle 20 Minuten checken. Ob die schon tot sind oder was? Ob sie noch atmen? Ob alles cool ist. Wenn du sie betäubst, dann musst du ja gerade nicht mehr checken. Ja, ich finde schon, auch schon, also da musst du nicht checken, ob die alles in Ordnung ist, aber dass die noch atmen. Aber das ist tatsächlich der Punkt, dass die beiden Geschwister von Madeline durchgeschlafen haben, auch als dann die ganzen Nachbarn kamen und die Wohnung durchsucht haben, haben die trotzdem noch weiter geschlafen. Aber meinst du dann, die betäuben dann jede Nacht ihr Kind, oder was? Weil die wären ja nicht nur an dem Abend in der Tapas-Bar gewesen, ich meine, ich war in der Tapas-Bar, wenn du einmal in der Tapas-Bar gehst, du gehst danach jede freie Minute willst in dieser Tapas-Bar verbringen. Ich finde auch der Begriff Bar an der Stelle toll. Ja, das war ein Imbiss. Naja, ich muss sagen, ich habe danach dort auf die Kinder geachtet und die waren schon immer sehr müde. Naja gut, aber vielleicht haben das Kinder so an sich. Das wenn sie vor die Kamera geworfen. Moment, du meinst, dass die Eltern einfach konstant ihre Kinder betäuben, oder was? Selbst wenn sie damit ihre Tochter umgebracht haben. Die haben die nicht umgebracht, das glaube ich nicht. Ja, also was dann? Ja gut, aber wenn eine Möglichkeit ist, dass eine Überdosis gestorben. Aber dann kannst du den Eltern ja trotzdem keinen Vorwurf machen, wenn das Kind geklaut wurde, weil sie betäubt war. Nee, ich habe nur gesagt, ich habe nicht gesagt, ich habe den keinen Vorwurf gemacht. Ich sehe nur zwei Probleme. Die sind Entführer und dass der Vater seine feinen Kinder betäubt. Gut, du konzentrierst dich eher darauf, dass sie schlechte Eltern sind, als dass ihr Kind verschwunden ist. Nee, das ist schon problematisch. Aber diese ganze, das geht für mich trotzdem nicht zusammen mit dem Verhalten der Eltern so ein bisschen. Naja, schau dich auf jeden Fall diese Doku an. Ich meine, wir sind beide keine Eltern. Ich glaube, wir wissen nicht, wie es ist, einfach mal zu sagen, das machen Eltern wahrscheinlich ständig. Ich glaube die meisten Eltern, ich glaube nicht. Wer ist so ein gutes Elternteil? Nein. Ich glaube, der Unterschied, wie sich Eltern anderen Eltern vor allem gegenüber zeigen und wie sie wirklich sind, ist enorm. Dass sie natürlich sagt, dass ihnen ständig ihr Kind runterfällt. Immer so dieses oben, natürlich fällt dir ständig dein Kind runter, hallo, mir fallen ständig Sachen runter. Und dein Kind, klar, die ersten Monate sind vielleicht magisch, aber danach ist es halt auch nur wie so ein Haustier. Und dann fällt sie halt runter und du sagst, wups und gibst es wieder auf. Ich habe keine Ahnung, Leute. Nee, auf jeden Fall diese ganze Theorie, dass die die umgebracht haben selber und dann im Kühlschrank versteckt haben, so ein Quatsch. Das ist Bullshit.
Aber dann fallen die so los, dass dieser Hund, der den Kadaver riecht und Leichenreiste riecht, dass er dann ausgeschlagen hat, den Mietwagen, den die 25 Tage, nachdem die Tochter gestorben ist, geholt haben. Super merkwürdig. Ja, merkwürdig und aber auch interessant. Und man will auch gar nicht wissen, was in so einem Mietwagen alles passiert, dachte ich mir dann. Vor allem, die haben ja gesagt, diese Hunde. Nur, dass sie damit ...
Angenommen, als Elternteil weisst du, ich habe meine Tochter nicht umgebracht, der Hund riecht Leichenteile im Kofferraum, danach sind die immer noch straight mit diesem Auto rumgefahren. Irgendwann, und vor allem die haben ja das Wissen, die wissen, ich als Zuschauer denke mir, okay, die haben ihre Tochter umgebracht, klar fahren die doch mit diesem Auto rum, wollen keinen Anschein erwecken. Aber wenn du wirklich deine Tochter nicht umgebracht hast und der Hund, der Polizeihund riecht eine Leiche im Kofferraum, dass sie ja noch straight mit diesem Auto rumfahren. Und die sich so, ich meine, wir wissen ja nicht, dass wir sie nicht umgebracht haben, aber schon strange, dass meine Leiche in unserem Kofferraum lag, oder? Vor allem die Hunde sind ja unglaublich krass und die haben gesagt, die können Leichen noch 40 Jahre, nachdem sie irgendwo waren. Die riechen die ganze Zeit Leichen. Du hast eine Leiche, legst die in einen Raum, legst die wieder aus dem Raum raus und 40 Jahre später kommt ein Hund in den Raum und sagt, hier lag mal eine Leiche für einen Tag. Das heißt, deswegen habe ich diese ganzen Funde der Hunde auch überhaupt nicht mit dem Fall in Verbindung gemacht, weil du immer denken musst, 40 Jahre riechen die, wenn die sagen, ja hier auf dem Sofa war Blut. Ja, innerhalb von 40 Jahren. Den kannst du in jedes Hotelzimmer schicken und überall riecht er das. Ich glaube, in jedem Zimmer ist innerhalb von 100 Jahren jemand gestorben. Ja, glaub doch. In jedem Zimmer der Welt. Aber der arme Hund, der darauf trainiert wird, der wird auch nicht mehr glücklich in seinem Leben. Ja, vor allem der also, wenn du wirklich... Furchtbar so... Wo riecht man denn keine Leichen innerhalb von 40 Jahren? In jedem Haus ist mal jemand... Gehen wir mal über den Friedhof. In jedem Haus ist mal jemand gestorben, in jedem. Also der musste überall anschlagen. Warum betont sie das? Ja, einfach nur, weil ich verteidige die Eltern. Ich glaube nämlich nicht, dass es die Eltern waren. Das glaube ich nämlich auch nicht. Das sindürfe sind totaler Bullshit. Ja, glaube ich auch. Ich glaube nur trotzdem, dass sie ihre Kinder sedieren. Aber fände es ja nicht auch gut Staffel zwei, der Mord im Mietwagen, dann einfach so, dass sie einfach Madeleine vergessen und irgendwann umschwenken auf den Mord im Mietwagen. Aber daran sieht man mal, wie schwierig das auch ist, in der heutigen Zeit jemanden umzubringen und die Leiche loszuwerden, ohne dass du gefunden wirst, ist, glaube ich, extrem, extrem schwierig, gerade in Deutschland. Also Rebecca. Natürlich diese Aufmerksamkeit, die in dieser Fall bekommt, kriegt natürlich nicht jeder Fall. Ich meine, für jeden Medlin gibt es 10.000 andere Kinder, die niemand interessiert. Ja, das hat die Doku ja auch schon gut kommentiert, aber... Kann man nicht einfach einen Hund darauf trainieren, dass er Kinder findet? Wäre es nicht leichter, einen Hund zu haben, der Kinder findet? Ja, und vor allem kann man Kinder nicht einfach was reinballern. Und das muss ja nur aktiviert werden. Vielleicht, das kann, muss man ja sagen, es kann nur aktiviert werden, damit Helikopter-Eltern nicht getriggert werden. Es kann nur aktiviert werden, wenn das Kind als vermisst gemeldet wird. Dann wird dieser Chip aktiviert und man weiß, wo es ist. Warum hat das nicht jeder Mensch? Und dann muss es wirklich gerichtlich angeordnet werden, dass man den dann finden kann. So wie man dann auch anfangen kann im Telefonat, ist das genau das Gleiche. Aber ich meine, wenn wir jetzt wirklich von einem skrupellosen Entführer ausgehen, dann pult der der halt den Chip raus. Nee, bei jedem Menschen ist der woanders.
Ja, gut, aber das ist sehr bürokratisch.
Manche haben Pech, da ist er genau auf der Stirn,
aber es ist bei jedem woanders.
Wie so ein Fingerabdruck wird das ausgelost,
wo man den reinballert.
Es wird sehr kompliziert.
Es ist nur ein sehr kleiner Pigment.
Und da läuft ein Windows-98 drauf, oder was?
Und zehn Jahre später denkst du dir, ich habe irgendwie ein scheiß Betriebssystem. Du weißt auch nicht, wo es ist. Du weißt selber auch nicht, wo es ist. Wenn dann irgendwie so ein Virus oder dann hast du irgendwie so ein Windows Vista oder so einen Scheiß da drauf. Ist sehr krebserregend leider, dieses Ding. Und alle kriegen immer genau da Krebs. Sie haben Prostatakrebs. Schreibt mir eine Kurzgeschichte. Schreibt mir eine Kurzgeschichte über das einzige Kind, das nicht diesen Chip hat. Und dann irgendwie alle sagen, warum wollten deine Eltern eigentlich nicht, dass du diesen Chip hast. Was dann vermisst wird. Und dann haut das Kind ab und dann sagen alle, ja, selber schuld. Und dann hilft dir nämlich niemand. Und dann nur der und der Hund, der nichts mehr zu tun hat. Und dann findet das Kind so einen geheimen Strand. Genau, und dann der Hund, der nichts mehr zu tun hat, der arbeitslos ist, rufen die dann an. Und dann sagt der, oh, endlich will man wieder was. Wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff, wuff. Ist schwer umzusetzen im Skript, aber okay. Und dann suchen die zusammen das Mädchen. Ist eine geile Story, kenne sie gut zwei, drei Seiten voll. Ja, darum geht's auch. Schreibt das mal. Wir haben noch eine kleine Ankündigung zu machen. Und zwar werden wir bald und es ist eine Neuerung im Podcast Ufo und wir haben es lange nicht gemacht, aber jetzt kommt der Punkt, wo wir uns dazu entschieden haben, es zu machen, wir werden, ich glaube, in drei Folgen oder so damit anfangen, ein kleines bisschen Werbung zu machen. Genau, es geht nur um einen kleinen Minispot in der Mitte jedes Podcasts. Es wird wirklich nur minimal sein, in der Mitte der Folge ganz kurz. Wir können natürlich verstehen, wenn Leute das scheiße finden, aber deswegen kriegt ihr diese Warnung. Und auch an alle, die uns per Patreon unterstützen. Ihr könnt es auch skippen. Natürlich. An alle, die uns per Patreon unterstützen, haben wir schon eine Nachricht rausgehauen. Aber vielen, vielen Dank nochmal an alle. Wir verstehen es total, dass wenn ihr jetzt sagt, keine Ahnung, die haben jetzt auch andere Geldquellen, die sind nicht mehr so auf meine Spende angewiesen, sind wir auch dann nicht mehr, sind wir auch ganz ehrlich, und ihr habt jetzt auf jeden Fall noch die Möglichkeit, eure Spende zu deaktivieren an dem Punkt, wir nehmen es niemandem übel, aber wir fordern es natürlich auf alle, die weiter stimmen.
Es ist nur für uns gut, langfristig unabhängig zu bleiben, vielleicht mal andere Projekte zu finanzieren und die Zeit zu nutzen, in der wir das, was wir gerne machen, hier zu Geld machen können.
Ich meine, Stefan hat zwei Kurzgeschichten-Ideen pro Woche, wir müssen das alles verfilmen, wir müssen da überall Skripte schreiben, es muss alles im Schnitt abgelehnt werden, es muss alles unterm Tisch geschoben werden.
Genau, dafür ist es uns aber wichtig, dass wir auf jeder Plattform verfügbar sind und barrierefrei. Kann man uns hören. Das Podcast-Lufo.
Keine Treppen.
Keine Paywall. Es gibt keine Paywall. Wir sind nicht nur bei Spotify Premium, wir sind überall zu hören. Und ich finde es okay, wenn man dann dafür ein bisschen Werbung macht. Ganz kurz nur einmal pro Folge. Ja, wir gucken mal, wie es läuft, aber wir machen, ich glaube, das wird gut funktionieren und jetzt auch keine so große Irritation sein. Und wir danken euch weiter für eure Unterstützung und dass ihr so tolle Hörer seid. Ihr seid richtig gut. Besonders du, Malte. Und du, Caro. Ihr seid die besten. Ihr seid die beiden besten Hörer. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf nächste Woche. Vielleicht haben wir nächste Woche, kleiner Teaser, wieder einen kleinen Beitrag von Thais im Podcast. Wir wissen es nicht, sie ist fleissig. Sie wetzt durch die ganze Welt und fängt ihre Erfahrungen an. Nächste Woche haben wir eine coole Neuigkeit zu verkünden. Die kommt schon jetzt bald raus, morgen.
Mal gucken, wann wir die Folge hochladen.
Ja, auch cool. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ich weiß selber noch nicht, worum es geht.
Ansonsten haut rein. Vielen Dank an Ben nochmal für das fantastische Intro.
Vielen Dank an Ben!
Macht's gut, wir müssen doppelt abheben, wir sind in Essen nicht abgehoben, deswegen ein doppeltes Abheben.
Einmal.
Jetzt ist das Essen raus.
Macht's gut, bis nächste Woche.
Ciao.